um all right so the album's coming out
win
August 25th that's very soon yeah that's
two weeks away three weeks away [__]
what do you say the seventh yeah like
three weeks what is today bro the 11th
I don't even know today today's the
fourth holy [__] dog I see like my whole
life yeah I have no idea what's going on
anywhere today's the fourth all right
yeah three weeks away the debut album
I'm very excited for it debut album man
yeah uh a lot of people looking forward
to this man I don't know it's gonna
touch a lot of people too bro have you
picked the next single yet obviously the
Chris Brown song is going crazy but have
you guys picked the next thing or you're
gonna let the fans we dropped another
one like we dropped a single two weeks
ago that was that's when it comes to you
who's on there wasn't that what me that
was just you okay I didn't hear that so
the Chris Brown Jump and we dropped when
it comes to you it's going crazy right
now the video is going crazy and you
know what's gonna happen when the album
comes out you guys are gonna see them
streams go up or whatever record and
that's usually I feel like that's kind
of the new way to
you throw out the singles and then you
put the owl mountain in the fans kind of
gravitate towards yeah especially with
these bigger artists now the labels will
hit me and they'll be like hey which
song Do you like on the album that just
came out with no note like Utopia right
like no one likes K-pop probably the
worst song in the album I think you're
crazy it is the worst song on the album
it's not a terrible song I love Utopia
to each his own but it's like if you're
gonna go with a record you gotta go with
the Meltdown right
to each his own what's your favorite do
you like well first of all what are your
thoughts on Utopia
it's a great album great production
yeah I liked it yeah I I like it yeah
what was your what's your album of the
year so far this year beside you you
can't say great question don't say
yourself album of the year
let me go on my phone
because the narrative is it's been a
pretty rough year for music it's been a
crazy year not the best year
[Music]
hip hop is like like you said it's been
I don't feel like [__]
[__] not focused no more how they used
to be like that's why in my opinion the
best album of the year so far is killer
Mike's album I heard that she was crazy
and somebody played me that John too
it's a joint Andre 3000 on there killing
my future hard yep Andre 3 000. she also
worked on that album for like four years
so that's I mean listen based off that
song alone bro
production
Cadence real music bro and that's like
I'm saying like
that music is not being pushed in front
of the the [__] like he dropped the
album of the year on some rap [__] when
I listen yeah but it's like so much
[__] be put in front of our face the
real music is pushed in their back bro
like you know what I'm saying so
I feel like [__] Gotta start
back I feel like back then bro
all the all the um the [__] that was put
in front of our face it had some like
it's structure to us right right you
know what I'm saying like 50 Cent these
[__] was making hooks that everybody
could sing bro like they said I'm gonna
get your take because you're a
songwriter right I'll I feel for
whatever reason right now like the women
in hip-hop are like the only people who
are really kind of applying themselves
and trying to make real records and I
don't know if that's because
you know they're in with more riders or
they they're they're trying I just feel
like women are making the most palatable
records with structure with hooks with
like Melodies like it just
I feel like they're really running
circles around uh male artists right now
in terms of just like when you turn the
radio on like I didn't have any way yeah
like the chicks are killing it I should
just shout out to sexy red dog uh she
having no way like
I I think they killing it more because
they being themselves type of [__]
they're not trying too hard
being them and just you know what I'm
saying even you they raw version of
themselves and I also think women are
very like uh for whatever reason a lot
of women artists are like extremely open
to like bringing in help for melodies
for hooks I'm not saying for verses but
you know no men are and you the [__]
is too
yeah I mean but you can't you just can't
hear it in in the songs yeah
because [__] is just rapping
like three minutes and you're like wait
where's the hook you like oh that's the
hook
like oh bro these [__] just making
these [__] a rap a whole song
and just make the song title as
something they said in the phone they
always got no hook and then the hook is
just like I sounds like an extension of
a verse and then when you hear it back
again yes and it's the laziest [__]
whatever they said in the verse Oh my
God they would name the title of the
song oh it's the [__] bro we need a
new we need a new age 50 Cent bro we
need something this [__] 50 Cent made
hooks he sure did Ja Rule Nelly you know
yeah hooks bro like
so when you in the club everybody's
singing that hook bro like that [__]
that's why I think Hip Hop not worse it
need to be right now bro I agree with
you man people gotta start making
records again yeah shout out to uh to
everybody out there trying though you
know I mean look Friday the album comes
out on August 25th yeah which is also a
Friday
would only be right your album comes out
on a Friday well all albums come out on
a Friday but we're gonna act like this
is on purpose you know back in the day
on a Friday if it came out on Tuesday it
was still a joke and look at us filming
this interview on a Friday sure Jesus
you know like we're super woke and all
that shit's lining up and there's some
sort of hidden meaning in that and we're
gonna decipher and let the fans kind of
figure out how Illuminati is involved in
this interview Friday dropping out on
Friday while being interviewed on a
Friday all right there it is man
appreciate you brother all right boom